hola como estan soy marina pueden oír
bien
bueno antes de empezar quiero dar una
advertencia de que voy a hablar de
nuestros límites biológicos por si
alguna persona se siente incómoda con
este tema
y bueno voy a compartir mi pantalla
podemos verlo bien
perfecto bueno hoy hablaré sobre lo que
verdad pasó en el 2019 he llegado a un
punto en el que la verdad no hablo de
esto porque siento que fue una
experiencia traumática pero al mismo
tiempo siento que le ha contado muchas
veces pero decía hacer una excepción
porque siento uno siento que esto es una
un ejemplo perfecto para explicarles lo
que significa la palabra sin límites a
mí y segundo porque cada vez que cuanto
y su historia siento que aprendo algo
nuevo sobre mí ok entonces hoy hablaré
sobre algunas cosas que tal vez suenen
desalentadoras al principio pero prometo
que la conclusión han ascendido y tal
vez les dará un poco más de perspectiva
lo que de verdad personal 2019 cualquier
por primera vez me sentí limitada en
toda mi vida cuando estás en la
preparatoria
con esta es la preparatoria tú te
sientes invencible sientes como si nada
te pudiera parar ya veces se podría
decir que se tiene un complejo de dios
en este momento de mi vida muchas veces
también te puedes sentir como si esto
fuera lo mejor que te vaya a pasar pero
por experiencia les puedo decir tiene
definitivamente no es así en julio de
2019 estaba terminando la preparatoria
estaba en esta etapa en la que los de la
escuela en la que todo lo que has
esperado por los 12 años pasas los
bailes las despedidas las salidas
graduación etcétera un día sentí algo
raro en mi tórax con depresión mi rutina
me di cuenta de que no tenía la misma
condición física del otro día todo había
cambiado en un par de horas
me di cuenta esto porque me di cuenta
que no podía hacer más de 10 workshops
esto tal vez no fue el mejor punto de
comparación porque la verdad es que
antes igual no podía hacer wikis pero
definitivamente notaba que había algo
diferente en mi condición física y en mi
cuerpo por ejemplo al subir las
escaleras del colegio me respeto ya que
estaba muy rápido estaba haciendo cosas
tan simples y mi cuerpo no estaba
aguantando el esfuerzo que usualmente se
aguantaba no podía dormir no puede hacer
ejercicio y cada vez que me podía cada
día me ponía más nerviosa porque
usualmente cuando se trata de buenos
pulmones eso significa no es muy serio
no estaba segura de lo que era pero
según yo me creía médica o simplemente
por el hecho de que estaba en biología y
decidí que no era nada grave entonces
estuve sin ir al hospital
aproximadamente tres días en otras
palabras
estuve hiperventilado por 72 horas
seguidas el día antes de ir al hospital
decidí buscar mis síntomas en internet
algo que no se los recomiendo estos
fueron los resultados me acuerdo que ese
día me di cuenta que ninguna de las
opciones era buena y que tampoco tenían
sentido porque él no entendía lo que
estaba pasando en mi cuerpo y que tal
vez era hora de ir a visitar un médico
después que llegue al doctor me llamaron
inmediatamente a emergencias mis
pulmones habían reducido al 50% de su
capacidad lo que llaman un hemotórax
bilateral la verdad es que hasta vendía
no logra entender lo que es una motora
bilateral pero siento que lo puedo
simplificar para ustedes
un hemotórax jazz con otros pulmones con
la persona esto es cuando entra a entra
aire a tus pulmones y entra en el
espacio entre la pleura y el pulmón como
podemos ver en la sección blanca
en el es en el en el escaneo de los
pulmones
en otro momento tal vez se hubiera
decidido el hospital más temprano tal
vez un día antes tal vez pudiera hacer
que mi conexión hubiera estado mejor
pero llega un punto al que empuje los
límites de mi cuerpo más de lo que
físicamente era capaz cual es
simplemente el simple hecho de que en mi
cabeza esos límites no existían mi mente
y mi cuerpo no estaban de acuerdo el
aspecto de visualizar las cosas es muy
común en el humano pequeños nos enseñan
que si queremos lograr algo lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es visualizar el
éxito
cuando esto siendo que es un aspecto
super importante cuando nos proponemos
algo siento que cuando se trata de
nuestro cuerpo puede ser engañoso
definitivamente es súper importante
cuando nos proponemos algo pero tampoco
siento que deberíamos basar nuestras
futuras decisiones en el hecho de si lo
podemos visualizar o no por ejemplo
muchas veces me pasa que siento que
pudiera ser buena en algo por el simple
hecho de que puedo visualizarlo
perfectamente el otro día me dieron
muchas ganas de ir a patinar
y después de ver los vídeos de algunos
trucos me propuse que iba a sacar un
truco y yo podía visualizar mis
movimientos perfectamente sabía
exactamente lo que tenía que hacer los
movimientos que tenía que tomar porque
uno siendo que como bailarín ayudaría de
experiencia suficiente como para
aprender a patinar y hacer algunos de
estos trucos pero el hecho de que lo
podía visualizar nunca significó que me
iba a salir a la primera este día me caí
tres veces intentando ni siquiera hacer
el truco patinar en general no me salía
después de mucho tiempo
practicando o caminando la persona sea
libre pero digamos que visualizarlo
simplemente me dio la fuerza para
empezar y atreverme a patinar pero no
significaba que me iba a salir cuando me
dieron hemotórax
yo visualice que podía seguir viviendo
así que no era absolutamente nada
visualice que se me iba a ir en algunos
días y como quería tanto creer que esto
fuera verdad me convence en mi cabeza
que de hecho era así que mi mente estaba
en lo correcto en mi mente no había
ningún solo límite pero mi cuerpo dijo
lo contario después de algunas semanas
en el hospital me operaron dos veces
y después vino el camino de recuperación
pero la recuperación fue aún peor peor
en la manera de que en este momento en
adelante me volvía cada vez más
consciente de los límites de mi cuerpo
algo que usualmente cuando eres joven no
es muy común y de hecho se empieza a
desarrollar mientras estás creciendo
al empezar mi proceso de recuperación
empecé a darme cuenta de todos los
límites de mi cuerpo
las primeras edad reposo y descanso me
acuerdo que todo este tiempo me la pasé
imaginando las cosas iba a ser cuando
saliera de allí entregasen bailar
estirar en una fiesta etcétera en el
momento nunca me puse a pensar sobre las
cosas que tal vez nunca iba a poder a
volver a hacer en mi vida o tal vez por
mucho tiempo entonces lo primero que no
quiero hablar es que fue muy difícil de
analizar que mi condición física nunca
iba a ser la misma es no importaba
cuánto me pusiera a entrenar o cuánto me
dedicara mi capacidad pulmonar nunca iba
a ser la misma de la que era antes como
le dije tiene en adelante fue un tiempo
en el que móvil me volvió a encontrar a
mí misma mi propio cuerpo cuando volví a
empezar a entrenar el baile cumbre se
hace muy difícil
bailar es cardio y es un ejercicio
aeróbico lo que significa que tiene que
haber un flujo continuo de oxígeno y
esto causa mucho estrés en los pulmones
antes de empezar a contarles mi
experiencia de recuperación quiero
mostrarles esto esto es un espirómetro
esto fue algo que hice durante el
proceso de mi recuperación que es una
herramienta para medir el volumen de lo
que está esperando entonces el propósito
es levantar las tres pelotitas hacia
arriba y nadando no exhalan no entonces
esto me dio varios ataques de ansiedad
ya que nunca logré levantar las tres
pelotitas por más de tres segundos hoy
en día si lo logra hacer pero en mi
cabeza es el límite siempre existió yo
nunca nunca pensé que esta vena duro las
cosas iban a cambiar que tal es ese
límite no iba a existir
entonces me puse un límite que no
existía simplemente por el hecho de que
ambiente y estaba con densidad de que
nunca lo iba a lograr
continuamos con
y empezar a bailar de vuelta podía
bailar todavía tenía la habilidad de
hacerlo por eso no era suficiente mi
cuerpo no estaba de acuerdo con mi mente
de las primeras veces fue decepcionante
verme a mí misma en algo que según yo
era uno de mis talentos y que era algo
que yo amaba más en el mundo y no poder
hacerlo correctamente tenía que tomar
procesos cada 10 minutos para poder
continuar y después de este primer mes
intentando bailar teatristas a decirlo
pero así lo dejé como coro tres semanas
que no fue tan largo pero en la
experiencia que tiene una bailarina que
se baila casi todos los días esto fue
mucho tiempo y lo dejé por un tiempo
porque no estaba lista no conociste a mi
cuerpo ni mis límites y tampoco quería
llegar a saber si me iba a salir igual o
si no me iba a salir igual o sea había
nuevos límites entonces cuando terminan
las primeras semanas me empecé a mover y
aquí fue cuando me di cuenta de los
cambios de mi cuerpo
el primer cambio fue de desactivación
obviamente era claro que mis pulmones no
iban a regresar por mucho tiempo
como les dije el espirómetro me causó
mucho sostener porque era tener que
intentará volver a respirar de vuelta y
reconocer que tu cuerpo tal vez no iba a
ser lo mismo y uno con el proceso en el
que estás creciendo
primero que todo te encuentras a ti
misma en tu cuerpo y debajo un punto en
el que sientes cómoda y sientes confiar
lo que puedas y no puedes hacer y para
mí esto fue empezar de cero tener que
volver a ver de misma encontrar cuáles
grandes límites y encontrar que era que
era lo que era capaz de hacer y lo que
no era capaz de hacer
entonces cliente de lee un libro que se
llama se amolda a la medicina y lo que
importa al final este libro escrito por
hato los guantes que es un cirujano y un
investigador de salud pública este se me
hizo un libro extraordinario y
recomiendo que lo lean si algún día se
sienten limitados físicamente o conocer
a alguien que pueda necesitar algo para
que está conociendo su cuerpo otra vez
este libro tocó muchos puntos de los que
estoy hablando ahorita entonces quiero
mostrarles algunas frases que me
hicieron increíbles en mostrar lo que
siento pero que tal vez yo no lo puedo
explicar mis propias palabras como ven
en este libro se refiere últimamente al
límite físico más grande que tenemos los
humanos que es la muerte pero siendo que
este mismo pensamiento se puede aplicar
cuando tenemos algún límite físico que
nos previene de vivir y nuestra
habilidad de vivir sin límites
esta es la primera frase que les quiero
mostrar podemos concluir algunas cosas
nuestra falla más cruel en cómo tratamos
a los enfermos ya los ancianos es el
fracaso de reconocer que ellos tienen
prioridades más allá de estar a salvo de
vivir más tiempo que la oportunidad de
darle forma a nuestra historia es
esencial para sostener el sentido de la
vida
esta frase me hizo reflexionar mucho
como una persona enferma de que va a
tener una condición preexistente
pulmonar por mucho tiempo siento que
esto también se puede aplicar a mí todo
lo que pedimos es continuar siendo
escritores de nuestra propia historia es
por esto que cuando nuestro cuerpo y
nuestra mente no están en sintonía y nos
llega esa amenaza de que tal vez no
vamos a hacer la misma persona que
éramos antes es probablemente el peor
aspecto no no estar saludable entonces
también quiero resaltar otra parte de
esta frase que es tenemos prioridades
más allá de estar a salvo y vivir más
tiempo esto para mí es el problema más
grande y las prioridades más para el más
allá de seguir precauciones de seguir
restricciones sobre lo que podía y lo
que no podía hacer ahora
yo quería bailar yo quería en la
universidad quería ir a la piscina
quería hacer tantas cosas y esas eran
mis prioridades
para seguir viviendo y seguir existiendo
en un nuevo mundo en el qué
si simplemente está existiendo y me
preguntabas cada vez que me iba a pasar
que podía pasar qué precauciones tiene
que tomar
estaba pensando como para pie como
paciente en vez de estar pensando como
persona que es algo que le pasa muy
frecuente pase mucho tiempo en el
hospital que esto es algo que todavía
hoy en día se me hace muy difícil es que
entra en mi mente y decirme ok porque
cuando tenemos una persona la única
pregunta que se te viene si lo vas a
hacer o no no es lo que pasa si me trago
los conejos que pasa así si ejército
mucho o se me sube la respiración
empiezo a hiperventilar o sea son
preguntas que me hago primero como
paciente en vez de personas otra frase
que me gusta mucho
esta frase que me gusta mucho es la
batalla de ser mortal es la batalla de
mantener integridad de nuestra vida de
prevenir volverse tan subyugado que
quienes somos es conecta de lo que
fuimos y lo que queremos ser es de esta
pérdida de pronto de a qué me refiero la
pérdida de control de nuestro cuerpo de
las opciones que tenemos de lo que tan
lejos
podemos llegar y lo que creemos que
somos capaces ahora podría hablar de
muchas cosas que predico en esta
experiencia como por ejemplo paz mental
entre otras pero siento que también haré
muchas cosas honestamente yo siento que
si no me hubiera pasado esto estuviera
en un lugar completamente diferente que
tal vez en ese momento era lo que quería
pero hoy en día no es lo mismo tampoco
quiero decir que por esta experiencia me
volviendo una persona porque no es así
sino que hubo cambios que dice que
desencadenaron por esta experiencia en
ti
entonces
vamos a continuar con esto quiero hablar
sobre algo súper importante que se llama
el crecimiento postraumático o como me
gusta llamarlo a mí la resiliencia esto
es a tener una experiencia así
definitivamente me hizo más alerta de
mis límites físicos pero también aprendí
a cómo controlar estas conciencias sobre
ellos y por esto quiero hablar de esto
esto se refiere al cambio positivo
experimenta una persona como resultado
de un proceso de lucha emprendido a
partir de un suceso traumático muchas
veces se habla de esto que experimentó
una persona cercana a la muerte pero
otra vez siento que es algo que se puede
aplicar a cualquier persona que tiene un
suceso traumático que ha sido familiar a
ti o que te ha afectado de una manera en
el que
afecta la conciencia sobre tu cuerpo y
sobre ti mismo es un choque de realidad
que causa relativizar los problemas o
revelar la importancia de lo que antes
creíamos que es importante tu mente de
una manera logra estar en sintonía con
tu cuerpo porque hay una nueva
comprensión sobre los límites de tu
cuerpo entonces tus prioridades están
tal vez ya no sean las mismas como dice
la principal cualidad que trae
crecimiento postraumático que de otras
maneras también se puede llamar la
autoconciencia de nuestro espíritu es
una cualidad que se empieza a
desarrollar muy tarde en nuestras vidas
entonces actuando igual de discute una
teoría super importante labor acorde nzl
ella es una directora de estudios de las
habilidades están por y siento que ella
describe esto de la manera exacta
cuando eres joven y tienes salud piensas
que vas a vivir para siempre no tienes
miedo a perder ninguna habilidad porque
no es una posibilidad de ningún momento
cercano la gente me dice el cielo es el
límite te dicen el mundo es tuyo y
sientes que tienes el chance de ponerle
pausa a otras cosas para poder cumplir
tus metas del futuro entonces la hora
cartensen explica cuando los horizontes
se miden en décadas que a veces es
considerado un tiempo infinito para el
humano deseas todo lo que está arriba de
la pirámide de maslow
aquí podemos ver logros creatividad
atributos de autorrealización por
ejemplo en mi caso ir a la universidad
bailar para un artista y otras metas
personales que básicamente son basadas
en nuestros deseos y logros que queremos
para el futuro pero con los dos
horizontes se encontraren cuando es el
futuro incierto y finito tu enfoque
cambia al ahora a los placeres de la
vida diaria a la gente más cercana a ti
y esto como podemos ver al final
hasta abajo de la pirámide de maslow
fisiológicas seguridad personal empleo
salud personales familiares sociales
amistades familias conexiones
[Música]
lo que tú puedes acercarte lo más
cercano a ti se contrae y esto es por
qué
vemos el futuro como finito e incierto
pero también porque la manera como
decidimos usar nuestro tiempo a veces
depende en cuánto tiempo percibimos que
tenemos
ahora lo que quiero decir esto no
significa que no estoy siguiendo mis
metas ni que puse un pausa en mis sueños
simplemente por el hecho de que sé lo
que viene a la mente mío sino que se
cree en nueva importancia en cosas que
tal vez antes eran diarias para ti eran
cosas que no pensabas que no le damos
mucha importancia al principio de una
manera y todo este cambio empecé a pesar
apreciar algunas cosas no por el hecho
de que podría traerme autorrealización
sino por el hecho de que sean feliz o
simplemente se sentía bien
por ejemplo bailar es algo que obvio
aunque era súper apasionada creo que vi
atrás a través de un factor competitivo
que quiero hacer con el futuro con esto
donde me va a llevar hoy en día existen
nuestros pensamientos también pero no es
lo primero que me viene a la mente lo
primero es que canción va a bailar como
me hace sentir y simplemente por el
hecho de bailar de una manera ahora tomo
las cosas de día a día porque uno piensa
que todo el tiempo diciendo lo cual no
es malo para el menos para mí siento que
planear para algo tan inseguro a veces
no será sobre las posibilidades
y el potencial que tiene el día de hoy
es nada más como humano querer planear
el futuro pero porque el planear para
210 años
si puedes traer por las siguientes dos
horas por los siguientes 10 10 días que
tampoco están garantizadas pero al menos
están más a nuestro alcance sé que todo
este tiempo charlie ha estado respirando
a los límites físicos de nuestro cuerpo
y como pueden ser obstáculos pero quiero
contradecirme después de todo esto y
decir que no importan los límites no
importan importa la manera en la que
pensamos estos límites van a seguir
existiendo aunque queramos que existan
lo que no queramos que existan existe
límite de cuánto podemos correr cuando
podemos bailar cuánto podemos hacer una
actividad por cierto tiempo por este
límite es temporal en ese exacto momento
ellos van a estar ahí pero por último es
nuestra decisión
si queremos reconocerlos o hacerlos
parte de nuestro día a día
nosotros tenemos el control de decidir
cómo vemos estos límites y pensamos que
son suficientes y si pensamos que son
suficientes
en nuestra vida diaria y estos límites
cuando lo ves por fuera y desde lejos
son tan diminutos
que puedas hacer lo que sea que te
propongas en tu vida los límites de
nuestra biología nuestros genes nuestros
huesos nuestros pulmones el corazón
nuestra piel etcétera
existen si para esto nuestra decisión de
cómo nos acercamos a ellos yo decidí que
existen son de verdad y tal vez no me
dejen estar bajo el agua por mucho
tiempo o bailar por mucho tiempo o
cantar canciones a todo volumen es así
que se me acabe el aire o tal vez o tal
vez hagan que me canse muy rápido como
me estoy cansando ahorita de seguir
hablando y hablar de hablarlo pero decir
que no me van a prevenir e intentarlo
porque tal vez tengan un riesgo pero si
yo decido que vale la pena el riesgo
entonces lo voy a hacer
gracias